tras la información publicada por from
para la especulación y el interés sobre
el allanamiento que hizo el fbi a la
mansión ademar a lago en la florida
américa hablan del fiscal general de
eeuu hizo una declaración pública donde
aclaró que el autor hizo personalmente
este allanamiento que hizo el fbi y
agregó que defenderá y no se quedará en
silencio al ver que los agentes del fbi
que llevaron a cabo esta misión están
siendo amenazados según fuentes cercanas
a lo ocurrido el lunes de esta semana el
fbi entró a la residencia del ex
presidente from pena florida y abrió una
caja fuerte y se llevó una docena de
cajas con supuesta información
confidencial que trump se habría llevado
de la casa blanca cuando era presidente
y no ha querido devolver estos detalles
no han sido confirmados por el fiscal
general para no interrumpir la
investigación pero de ser el caso cuando
habría violado la ley al guardar y no
devolver esta información confidencial y
clasificada esto le podría dar hasta
cinco años de cárcel según una ley que
él mismo firmó cuando era presidente
cabe mencionar que orden de allanamiento
no ha sido pública porque los abogados
de donald trump no han autorizado su
publicación y analistas dicen que trump
al final no terminara permitiendo que se
revele esta orden para no revelar
precisamente detalles y pruebas que
justifiquen el allanamiento que hizo el
fbi